pouvez vous nous expliquer comment vous
avez rejoint la campagne présidentielle
de l'actuel président de la république
monsieur mâcon j'ai été sollicité par un
camarade qui quand je dis camarades de
jeu pèse mes mots qui avait rejoint la
république en marche et qui m'a
sollicité au vu des compétences que je
pouvais avoir dans en termes
d'organisation et en termes pratico
pratique c'est à dire qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de personnes qui étaient
déjà dans les rangs de la république en
marche plus sur des thématiques de fond
sur des sujets de fond
mais une campagne présidentielle c'est
beaucoup de logistique beaucoup de
pratique et ça demande un certaine
expérience
j'ai une petite expérience avec la
campagne présidentielle de 2011 2012 et
donc il m'a demandé si j'étais intéressé
à savoir de venir aider à organiser des
déplacements du candidat des meetings
avec un certain nombre d'autres et donc
j'ai participé à ce travail
dès lors qu'il m'a sollicité j'ai trouvé
j'avais adoré l'expérience de la
campagne présidentielle c'est une
expérience unique que j'ai pu vivre en
et il ya les retourner quand on sait ce
que ça implique en terme d'engagement en
termes c'est passionnant la campagne
présidentielle donc j'y suis allé tout
le monde m'a dit que j'étais un peu fou
parce qu'il n'avait aucune chance
et quand j'ai rencontré le personnage
pour la première fois j'ai été séduit et
je me suis investi à l 100 % dans cette
campagne et on a commencé avec des
petits moyens on a grossi au fur et à
mesure dans un bon état d'esprit et le
candidat macron a pu devenir président
grâce à un certain nombre de personnes
qui ont fourni un travail mais c'était
que j'y suis allé parce que j'ai été
sollicité par un ancien camarade que
j'avais totale confiance connaissez mes
compétences mes capacités d'organisation
de logistique mon engagement
et voilà merci monsieur madame jourda
qui est cet ancien camarade je souhaite
le préserver pour le moment mais c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a travaillé à la
république en marche et qui travaille
toujours